[Music]
you guys know those
old or i don't know if they're old but
you know those chinese movies where like
people are like flying and stuff
yeah and then it's just it's like it's
called wusha i think ushu
i think wu yeah
it's like uh it's like saying like
marshall cinema
it's like its own genre in is that kung
fu movies it's like
it's like spaghetti western is like it's
exactly yeah yeah it's its own thing
kung fu movie because they have actual
kung fu movies like more like jackie
chan style
where it's they're fighting on the
ground and it's not really
super natural though wusha like that
that stuff is
it's like supernatural flying through
trees yeah yeah like that oh
fireballs and [ __ ] cinematic as [ __ ]
though so one is like
one is like uh lord of the rings and
then the other one's like game of
thrones
they're the same like what do you what's
the difference with those
i love your brain dude ones like denny's
one of game of thrones ones like denny's
ones like i have even in season one
there was dragons
joe never changed you little hats
couldn't get burned by fire no but at
the end they had yeah
okay one is like game of thrones
and the other one is like king arthur in
the knights of this round
when there's a floating sword that comes
to a table yeah yeah yeah yeah they they
get their reference right you're the
best
so there is this there's this tourist
attraction
in china you get to fly where you get to
fly oh
[ __ ] that'd be my childhood dream come
true i don't know if i trusted in china
can i do it
can i yeah can i just like peter pan and
do it well
please do please but like
but like a high school yeah yeah with
the
the little green stockings i'll pay for
everything deal
okay i'll wear elf shoes yeah and the
hat with the ears yeah [ __ ] you
i've been wanting to reenact chinese
kung fu movies ever since i was a kid i
tried to fly from my couch to the other
couch
yeah dude you gotta go here you gotta go
to
this it's in china it's in china i have
a video so it's
like the backdrop is like ancient china
it's so pretty and then they also give
you the
there better be a freaking old chinese
dude with the urhu
and like a big mole with the [ __ ]
hair that's gone and he has three teeth
and he's like
and then like people are doing kung fu
and [ __ ] yeah that would be dope i'm
gonna play it
can they just move the star acadia or
something i know right oh
that's this is that green screen oh no
that's fake grass yeah
whoa that's [ __ ] sick you had a
waterfall
sick yeah oh my god beautiful
oh i want to go to china just for this
yeah
oh that looks too high i've actually had
dreams where i'm i'm flying like this
but i'm attached to like uh
something and then i'm doing this exact
thing or i'm like what that's crazy i
want this to be my wedding video yeah
right
can we redo our wedding video yeah let's
do it those people look like they were
in a wedding
outfit yeah because the guy's like why
do we have to do weddings we could just
go
dress it looks so pretty dude that is so
tight
wait you're down to do this you're
afraid of heights on certain things
what does that mean so yes you're done
and do this [ __ ] yeah that's all in your
heart
there is no better way to stop
dude
[Laughter]
is it a fake location um i don't know it
looks
like a real waterfall yeah i know right
dude how much does it suck to be that uh
one of wendy's brothers in that play you
don't even know their name
michael and john you're like [ __ ]
chasing ah she fell
we can we can go with swords okay and we
battle it out in the sky
that's insane because it's only one at a
time
and then we do it and somebody dies like
we're not doing swords anymore
uh yeah there's a lot of velocity
happening even with a fake song someone
has a sword out and the other person is
like no
no i'm like
i'm swinging the door so i can't hear
that
together and the guy on the ground is
like this is so [ __ ] sick
dude that's scary i would imagine that
when they do the battle in the sky
the wires get tangled i want a star i
want a star wars theme one where the
everyone's on wires like that and you
play laser tag but you're in the sky
and you can like jump and fly to the
next thing oh that'd be so fun
nobody could find star wars oh but it's
really um i don't know you were a big
star wars i'm not apparently people
don't fly so you can't do this
who flies in star wars who the [ __ ]
flies in star wars you can jump
you're telling me those kids can't
figure out how to fly [ __ ]
losers yoda kind of flies because he's
so small
yeah but he doesn't fly that he that's
true he doesn't he jumps around in space
there's less gravity
it's kind of like you're flying you
would think there's no real
there's no real lack of gravity in star
wars i'll tell you that right now that's
true
because it would defeat the purpose of
having planes that's why they gotta get
in a plane that sounds fake then
we should do a theme park that's like uh
um
you can have the chinese experience but
it's the real one
like you get to go through all the
stages
of your parents disapproving of every
dream that you had
and then uh you finally go to college
and then you graduate and they never let
you date and then you finally graduate
and they tell you when are you gonna get
[ __ ] married there's a theme park
yep how do you go through these things
i don't like your theme parks you have
to pay to go in too does it sound fun
no thanks also remember you have to pay
to go in right you heard that part
not fun yeah okay got it but you can
also get season pass you can keep coming
back every single day oh that's like
oh in hopes of changing your parents
making them proud
yeah it sounded it sounded cool like at
the end of it it's like
yeah you got to make your parents proud
and if you need to leave and come back
they whip you one time so you come back
and show them their mark yeah i was here
joke's on you they're never proud right
yeah and then
you go yeah so you so it brings them
back to the theme park yeah the entrance
again
my theme park is next level it's florida
panhandle based
you're uh basically the attraction is
you're trying to win
at scratchers every day
that's your peoples that that's why
people do yeah like a knott's berry farm
when you go and you like pan for gold
i like that exactly i haven't been to a
long time it's like going there to get
rich
yeah like you're like this is gonna be
it tomorrow is it baby we're gonna find
them that's like vegas
but once a day like one person does win
to keep you motivated yeah
but it's the same person and they and
that person has to stand there the whole
time
he'd be like with a big check a big fake
check yeah
they really go home with a stuffed bear
but like i think it's the same guy every
day
they have to sit in those lawn chairs i
mean wow
when i saw this video i was like man
that's so fun it seems like such a fun
attraction
but it also reminded me of when i was a
really little girl like my mom like
my dad he he would leave channel 18
playing which is
i don't even know what what kind of it's
like all the languages like
indians vietnamese korean indian i
wonder if they're still around
so then sometimes they'd be playing kung
fu movies and so when i was
i think i was like four thinking this
but i was like
what like chinese people can fly that's
no they can't fly can they that's crazy
no and then like but i'd be skeptical
i'd be like
you've never seen casey floating in the
kitchen or he's making pasta
no but yeah and then
so uh but then every time i think about
that memory i'm like oh
tiffany you were four why would you be
embarrassed about a four-year-old
because it's such a silly thought even
though it's
like yeah i was four years old but just
thinking that even just me having that
thought is hilarious like which is
[ __ ] i think that
people in a whole race can fly i thought
santa could fly around the whole world
in one night until i was like 10.
that's true dude i just watched a
history video on santa too
i'll have to save it for a different
time is it
bad origins yes it's about how it's all
based on magic mushrooms
what oh that one yeah
well i mean we have time okay so
like everything represents you know how
mushrooms are like the one that's
well known throughout the world are the
ones that are bright red with the
white spots yeah okay so those
are like representative of like the
presents under the tree
and because they grow under trees and
when
these like um i forget what they're
called but they're like shamans
basically
they would collect them for people um
because they could get you they had
these toxins in them that could
that had hallucinogens and people really
liked them they were like a specialty
right
so every december the shamans would
collect them all
and they would give them to the people
and the way that they give them to the
people
during that time all their houses were
like kind of under ice and snow and
stuff
so the easiest way was to drop it down
the chimney so like that's how the
chimney thing happened
and then the way that they like dried
the mushrooms out because like they are
poisonous technically so you have to try
to get all the like the liquid to dry
out
they would hang them on the tree which
represents the ornaments that they hang
on the tree
and like the shaman guys themselves
would wear these red outfits
and they have like long white beards and
i don't know maybe they're hefty i don't
really know
but um they also said like they would
kind of be on the shrooms while they're
collecting them
and so sometimes it would and there
would be reindeer around
like eating these mushrooms too and
sometimes everyone's hiding
yeah they would look like the reindeer
were flying dude world history is just
it's just like drunk history yeah what
the [ __ ] there's a channel called after
school
after skool and they have a history
playlist yeah
and that's where i learned about the
gold and that's what i learned santa
being based on mushrooms well animated
too how did it become so [ __ ]
wholesome though from a mushroom fantasy
right true like christmas is like the
most wholesome [ __ ] of all
it makes you really happy you know like
i love christmas
yeah i thought it was based off of like
some nordic
thing it's a combination of all of it i
think
it probably started there and it went on
and then it's like mixed with
christianity now nordics had their own
thing
and then like the mushroom people were
like wait we have that too but they've
like got all those
we're watching people from uh wherever
the shamans are from
apparently it snows there because like
it's all icy and they put down the
chimney i don't watch the channel
after school they do a way better job at
explaining things than me but i was
watching it i was like
i kind of want to try mushrooms now i do
too my friends growing them
let's do it yeah everyone thinks i'm
getting into the illegal mushroom
business because of how much mushrooms
i'm
posting yeah they're just like oh that's
that's that's those uh magic mushrooms
so i'm like
nah it's shiitake it's uh but it sounds
like a regular
like they think i'm really starting to
get into the illegal
like psychedelic i mean based off of how
much you talked about your past
i wouldn't i wouldn't think and based on
the way you just said that they're
they're they're just shiitake mushrooms
don't worry about it
sounds like a good bit for sure and and
um you're like my cousin's growing them
what they're just shiitake mushrooms
prices went up the prices went up for
psychedelic mushrooms yeah
what the [ __ ] you're confusing people
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
do
you